doing it live in full effect
another week welcome here we go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
what's up y'all ripping with Griffin I
wanted to do this at 10 A.M but
stuff was happening but it don't matter
but today welcome back I'm talking about
this show swarm on Amazon Prime I binged
it all last night
mandalorians back got some weird news
stories
self-cleaning like headphones that clean
your ears weird social experiments
and just me being me
[Music]
yeah if you in your car right now you
and your semi truck you at work I know
you Bob in your head right now let's
come on now let everybody in the
workplace know what is this
[Music]
all right y'all
welcome back to River with Griffin it's
good to be here as usual uh thanks
everybody who is uh you know supporting
this show by coming in live on
Wednesdays you know we move the show to
Wednesdays it's ripping with Griffin you
know how we do it sometimes we doing
comedy sometimes I'm funny sometimes I'm
introspective sometimes I'm serious but
I'm always 100 me for that's for the new
people for the people that come here all
the time you already know what it is
thanks for being here I appreciate you
always ripping with Griffin go to
ericgriffin.com to check me out
uh subscribe make sure you subscribe to
the show y'all subscribe share let
everybody uh you know it helps me with
the algorithm and all that write
comments on the apple apple and all
those places to and I appreciate the
people listening to
so we got that and then I'm gonna be on
Twitch
you know love twitch Eric Griffin gaming
I'm doing that all the time so make sure
you come check that out I appreciate you
the ways to support the show though you
could be a patreon member you could be a
YouTube member
you could be a twitch sub you can Super
Chat like Janine just did and I totally
appreciate you girl every single week
you're great thank you very much uh
again like I say you could be a patreon
member and you know I just I keep saying
I'm gonna do I want I'm trying to do
this thing but I went to Fashion Week
with Rachel and I'll talk to you about
that but uh you know it is what it is
um
yeah so do all that stuff we're from
with Griffin uh what do I got coming up
if you want to come see me live you want
to come see me live Eric Griffin live in
full effect my April is packed April is
packed I'm gonna be at the um the the
Blue Room in Missouri the blue room and
uh that the slide's coming up wait let
me get the damn where where let me get
my calendar open yeah I should probably
have my calendar open when I'm doing
this but you know we do it live from
behind today it is what it is okay so uh
let's see April 13th through the 15th
the Blue Room okay and and in in
Missouri so come check me out there
Louisville Comedy Club the 20th to the
22nd come check that out and just booked
the new comedy club Joe Rogan's Comedy
Club the mothership in Austin I will be
in Austin the 28th through the 30th so
come check me out in Austin and I'm
gonna do Tony on the uh the first if
that if he's doing it that day so so I'm
gonna be in Austin area so come check me
out for their riffing with Griffin
okay guys Today's Show is brought to you
by Kick okay kick off
kick off don't let your credit control
you go to kickoff.com and start building
Better Credit in less than five minutes
don't put it off that's
k-i-k-o-f-f.com to take control of your
credit right now build your credit the
easy way right now at kickoff.com
okay uh how do you how how's everybody
doing
um you know I hope everybody's doing
well you know we had uh quite the uh uh
weekend I know I had a I had a great
weekend this weekend I went to I like
where was I I was in
um
I was in Palm Springs with Rachel you
know Rachel was doing Fashion Week
Rachel was walking in El Paseo Fashion
Week she's still there now actually uh
doing uh you know doing her thing you
know my Rachel's been now modeling for
like 20 plus years man she's uh she's
doing that so you know shout out to my
lovely wife doing Fashion Week even
though fashion week is expensive cost me
a lot of money
modeling is for modeling is for rich
girls and young naive girls who are
trying to like think that this is going
to make me a star you know what I mean
modeling is such a weird business but
anyways let's go to comments first
that's how we do it I want to talk about
comments that I got this week uh or you
know from last week's show or whatever
it is
let's see
um
uh Zach Stevens uh this is why the last
of us is a great story there are no
right or wrong answers objectively Joel
should let Ellie die to help Humanity
but we aren't objective we love we love
we what does he say we we love who we
love like who we like love Rachel EG
it's the argument of what's right versus
protecting who we love yes thank you uh
Zach I mean what an interesting debate
The Last of Us brought up you know what
would you do if your loved one your kid
your wife your brother your mother you
know they had the Cure that could save
Humanity do you do you know what I mean
what would you do it's a tough one you
know it's a tough one you know you're
almost like you let someone else decide
and then you know but that's actually
making the choice too right you know if
you say you decide because I am too you
know I'm too objective you know too
subjective I don't know that's a weird
one
uh
uh so this guy Noah
moroto Eric with with he's saying what
are you talking about with the NBA video
games don't don't give you control of
how you shoot it it's it's not the AI it
all depends on the style of shot and
user's timing and he laughs you are one
thousand percent wrong bro
the the the AI is based off the players
shooting percentage in real life right
or they they do an estimation they go
this guy shoots say he shoots 45 from
the field right so
there is no way whatever you do with the
controller that your player is going to
shoot a hundred percent like you're
gonna get nine out of nine shots they
won't allow it because then it would
just be complete fakeness right then you
would just get Steph Curry figure out
how to shoot the ball every single time
and make every single shot that's how
they do it so they're trying to make it
like where as if like well you know
where you know with your your hand
movements you're not gonna actually make
it do the same thing every time but
there is a way you get to that point
where you're getting pretty good no they
don't allow that because they want it to
feel realistic so the AI does
step in like sometimes you'll be
underneath the basket in one of those
basketball games and you got your player
and you're just shooting a layup the
dude's a seven footer and he can't make
a layup that's the game deciding [__] so
you're a thousand percent wrong but
thanks for the comment
anyways
uh somebody said your volumes are so low
for your pause I shouldn't be at max
volume on my phone or Bluetooth and
barely be able to hear you please speak
with uh something you know she said to
Pump Up the Volume I don't know what do
you guys think that's listening right
now is the volume too low to you guys
uh you know seems like I'm getting max
volume on my my meters right now so
maybe it's the audio version that's not
going out loud enough I don't know so
um yeah so I don't know why that I don't
actually I don't know why that is seems
like it should be coming out pretty loud
but you know I guess I gotta figure that
out but you know is what it is y'all
you know what I mean I mean my two
little baby do like this how about that
it's being that loud better hello I
don't know we're testing we're doing it
live so I turned it up just because I
heard saw that right there
greatest intro of all time no discussion
Alfonso alvalos thank you very much
let's see what else we got here
um
Belinda cross street said hell to the no
on Ranch ice cream
from last week's episode Ranch ice cream
I don't even know
let's see
um some people that got weird names I
wish everybody just had their name as
your username all this cowardly like
hiding behind these stupid names well
that's not always cowardly but it's just
a lot of times it's cowardly and other
times it's just you know just some dumb
thing that we used to do who are you
just put your name you know what I mean
you got something to say put your name
on it you know I don't know
um let's see another comment uh here's
another one about Last of Us from
Hugo harosa I think that's how you say
it Joe did what he did because on top of
everything else the fireflies knocked
Ellie out and didn't tell her what they
were doing so so Dan that automatically
made them suspect as he felt justified
in rescuing her yeah maybe but that's
also my comment on that is sometimes
like is that the Humane thing to do
let's say you had the cure for cancer in
you and uh you know not a you know
self-preservation kicks in you know you
might be an honorable person and I come
to you and I say uh hey um you had the
cure for cancer in you so I have to you
have to Die to Save everybody you may
make that choice you may be like you
know what kill me then but I mean do you
even want to take that risk or maybe is
it the Humane thing to do to say to you
hey you know you had the cure for cancer
in you and uh you know
but there may be some complications but
this could save Humanity you know it's
kind of soften it then you go yeah you
know what I want to save everybody and
then you just cut that [__] open
you know what I mean I don't know it's
like it depends on what you like you
know what what you want to hear but
anyway that's the comments from this
week and everybody thanks for
thanks for reaching out I appreciate
your comments
you know what I mean
um yeah I see what somebody else is
saying is she old enough to make that
that choice but you know I think she is
I think she's I actually think in the
show Ellie would have made the choice I
think Ellie would have been like kill me
I I I couldn't save my friends I
couldn't save everybody she's tired of
losing people and she survives I think
she would have made the choice I think
she would have made the right choice and
Joel was just like nah man
uh this is I can't you know what I mean
I I can't lose another person that I
care about and I can do something about
it you know what I mean
so yeah that's that on that um so
anyways guys um so yeah this week I was
in uh I went to uh Palm Springs I went
to uh you know Palm Springs with Rachel
and it was like really fun
um
you know she she was walking in Fashion
Week you know and she even had to stay
an extra day
you know so that so that was that was
kind of cool let me see if I can go to
her
Instagram right now you know and just
give Rachel a follow guys if you like
well girls too I don't care your guys
girls whatever yeah so Rachel's out
there in Fashion Week you know doing
doing her thing
um
you know so then she put like a lot of
videos of us eating
you know what I mean like we went to
like the different you know different
coffee shops and stuff like that but in
Palm Springs was really nice it's
actually a great time of year to be to
be in Palm Springs you know uh because
it's like the weather is like really
nice right now I was like in the 70s
yeah so she has a lot of videos from her
like you know getting ready and all
these like uh the crazy outfits that she
had to she had to wear look like some of
the the high fashion stuff I just don't
get yeah we were staying at that Hotel
Paseo really great Hotel uh yeah so here
she comes walking right now there she is
right there you know been doing it 20
years y'all 20 years modeling
so shout out to my lovely lady
uh yeah it was fun you know I don't know
I just I don't know about modeling you
know what I mean I don't know if it's
like I don't know if we I don't know if
it like has the same appeal that it once
did or how we look at it like you know
we had this like objectification that we
do with people models mostly female but
even the male models you know it's like
when you see like a a shirtless guy in
underwear on a billboard you know we're
you know we're objectifying this guy too
there are guys that have experienced
things you know there's it's just rare
when you hear about it because most like
because that's just not how it's just
not how men normally deal with that that
situation but it's like you know there
is this like perception that men have
never been sexually you know objectified
or like you know uh inappropriate things
I mean it happens a lot it's happened to
me many times and you know yeah if you
can believe that but it's like it's not
something that we like we just do we
could deal with it differently so in you
know but we don't like we're not putting
it out on Front Street all the time
whatever it is like that you know what I
mean not that I'm saying that that's
wrong I'm just saying it's like it's
just we deal with it differently so you
know I think the society has moved in a
different direction it's like you know
they don't we don't hear about the Miss
America Pageant as much as we used to or
Miss Universe and
this sort of parading women out for
their beauty for the world to see and
like you know we don't celebrate that
stuff as much as we did before and it's
probably a good thing you know you think
about all kinds of things that we still
have in society like that like
cheerleading like you know women dressed
up all sexy at restaurants or you know
whatever whatever the waitresses I'm
saying or like all the ways we use sex
to sell things uh or or we use sex to uh
sex and sexuality and you know Beauty as
a way of you know as a source of
entertainment I mean that's it's still
all there but those things that are
blatantly about that it's just not like
that anymore you know it's not because
even when I've been going like I I've
seen a shift even as I've gone to like a
bunch of Rachel's modeling shows you see
like now they're doing this thing where
it's like different body types different
ages you know what I mean you might see
a you know you know you see a thickie
walking down the the you know what I
mean she thick as hell walking down the
runway and you like okay big man [__]
you know what I mean do your thing you
know it's like natural and she's wearing
an outfit that I think people in the
audience are like okay you know what I
think I can I can wear that you know but
it's like it's not just you know it's
not the same as it once was
you know what I mean it's just I just I
feel like there's a shift in society but
what do you think maybe that maybe you
don't think there's a shift in society
but I do think there's been a huge shift
in society okay so I want to get to like
I want to I have some two reviews that
I'm gonna do today
one of them one of them is
um uh the Swarm on Amazon Prime
last night I watched the first episode
because somebody was telling me about it
and I actually saw this thing about like
Macaulay Culkin's brother I forgot the
guy something coken it's one of the
Culkin Brothers he has this sort of nude
scene you know he's got his like dick
smushed up against a a glass bowl of uh
strawberries like he gets into bed with
her when he puts the strawberries in his
lap and then the camera Zooms in through
the bowl and his dick is just smashed up
against the bowl and I'm just like what
is this show about you know what I mean
so they would make it a big deal so I
was like what's this show even about and
then I saw this poster for the show and
I was like this black girl and I was
like what is this about so I'm gonna
talk about that I'm gonna do that at the
end and then also mandalorian's back so
give him my thoughts about what's going
on
with that you know what first and
foremost before we even do that let me
give a word to our sponsor again kickoff
all right kickoff kickoff kickoff
um credit is such a big deal guys and
there's so many different ways to help
you get your credit but having good
credit is going to help you get better
interest rates for your credit cards for
buying a house for even when you're
renting whatever you're doing they check
your credit and having a great credit
score is super important so don't let
your credit control you uh getting ready
for the next step in your life I mean
this is like so important like I say
when you're going to buy a house you're
going to buy a car you need to have
amazing credit uh to get credit good
credit rewards and there's no way around
it credit scores are boring I'm just
gonna be honest talking about your
credit is boring but it is important to
this is how you adult adults need to
adult but they uh look they credit's
boring but they still determine what
kind of credit cards you get you know
what kind of interest rates all that
stuff is super important and I'm here to
tell you that you know having great
credit I I had to work on it and I'm
there now but I know what a struggle it
is so don't let your credit control you
go to kickoff.com and start building
Better Credit
in less than five minutes with a 4.9 out
of 5 rating in the App Store and over 44
000 rave reviews you can trust kickoff
to help you get ahead you can even set
it to Auto page you can build your
credit without even thinking about it
plans started like five dollars a month
and on every on-time payment you make
with kickoff is reported to the major
credit bureaus
when they see healthy habits it boosts
your credit don't put it off that's
k-i-k-o-f-f.com to take control of your
credit right now build your credit the
easy way right now at kickoff.com
okay so I had some some stories that I
wanted to go into today that I saw that
just like and this is one of the major
ones man this one is just like where's
this sucker man
um I had it right here oh oh this is
just this social experiment nonsense man
I just want to talk about this and this
is like this is the thing I realize is
when you when you that's making me feel
like an old fogy you know it's like I
don't want to feel like that but I'm
feeling like it so they got this social
experiment where singles across the
world are participating in the larger
social experiment ever conducted
so it's about like you know you're gonna
wear a ring so you don't have to be on
social apps you know so it said
according to vote 7600 people are open
to being chatted up in real life but how
do you know who's single and who's not
you know and so they're saying people
are going to wear this ring on their
finger and when you see that ring that's
gonna signal oh that person's single so
let me go talk to them
let me tell you what I find ridiculous
about this
okay let me tell you what I find
completely and utterly ridiculous about
this whole thing man all right
um
you need an experiment
to talk to other human beings in real
life
like this needs to be a a thing where
you have to buy a little ring as if like
you could trust everybody with this ring
that's telling the truth
as if
talking to people we are communal beings
we are people that need to be around
other people that's we need to laugh we
have six senses meant to interact with
other people and to survive you taste
smell hear see feel these are all things
that you need
we need that we have to help us interact
with other human beings so this idea and
listen you know again
I'm not anti-dating app at all I'm not
saying that okay I met Rachel on
Instagram all right I'm not saying that
but we got off of that right away I
invited her to my show right away she
came to my show right away and then we
hung out two days later at something
that she invited me to and then we went
on a date three days after that I'm just
telling you it's a great way to meet
people to be safe but don't rely on that
so I'm not being like you know get off
my lawn but you young people need to get
off your goddamn phones
stop texting people as your only way to
communicate do you know how much is Lost
in Translation
how about this
what happens in real life man
you wonder why a dude like me you know
I'm not the most handsome dude in the
whole wide world but I've done well in
my dating life and meeting people
because of what happens in real life I
have a boisterous personality I'm funny
I'm Charming I listen I make eye contact
I read body language these are all
things that are super important to
interacting with other human beings you
don't need no damn social experiment to
do what we had to do for 10 000 years
before the internet and cell phones you
young men you're so afraid of rejection
that you're not going in public and
being like hello so what a chick is like
hey you know what I think if there's any
women even listening right now don't you
want to be talked to don't you want a
person to be like a guy to be like showy
interest in you give you attention get
make eye contact be like hey how you
doing and then you can also feel like oh
this this is some crazy uh I'm getting
crazy vibes from this guy and you can
feel that right away how many times have
you been talking to somebody for months
texting like oh this is real I have such
a connection over text and then you meet
them in real life and you're like oh
what happened something's going on
that's because that ain't it's not
enough it's limited it's a limited
version of the person get out in real
life what are you guys doing you don't
need a social experiment go meet people
this is why and I tell you you wonder
why you think older guys do well you
think older guys do well with younger
women just because of what because of
money and things like and now man I'm
telling you it's because my generation
40s and up we we there was a time when
we didn't have the internet and cell
phones and we had to actually meet
people at bars we had to like you know
you're out someplace and you're like hey
what's up how you doing or are you like
a friend introduced to you to someone
and you had to go on blind dates and you
had to do that kind of stuff so like we
are more equipped you four enough you
more equipped you out in public like yo
what's up how you doing whatever and
then like that person women are like oh
my wow you're actually talking to me
because these young men are cowards
young men are cowards and they rely on
this like meat market they they're like
ooh swipe swipe and they always think
there's something better oh that girl's
prettier oh that girl's prettier you
don't know nothing about them you think
pretty is enough haven't you ever met
somebody pretty and they open their
mouth and you're like yuck you know what
I mean like it's like there's so much
more to human in interaction you know
what I mean like it's it's just like
you know it's like when when a person
has they're successful you know
like if you if you're a young man and
you're successful man use that like if
you're 30 and you got your own house and
you got a great job man that is just
it's that swag that not just the things
you have but how you got it you got it
by being confident and success you know
and like you you're a go-getter and you
know you're talented that's the thing
that's attractive it's not just like you
know money like if you think it's if if
you run across a person that all they
care about is money
you're gonna feel that and you'll be
able to move on but you'll be able to
feel that in person I just think you
don't need a social experiment to do
what we were designed to do that's why
we have a voice that's why we have eyes
that's why we have ears to listen feel
look communicate
I can't tell you how often that I'm
counseling someone you know I do real
world advice and people just hit me up I
have my friends that hit me up about you
know I had a friend of mine hitting me
up about some stuff and like they're
texting and I say you can't text this
when you're having a listen if you're
having an issue with a loved one a lover
a friend a family member
do not text them in the middle of a
heated whatever don't text
you need to tell them hey can we talk
about this on the phone get on FaceTime
can we meet for coffee can we get
because it will be different it will be
this sort of fake Internet courage that
people have when they're texting and
they think oh I could say whatever you
know there is something about being held
accountable for your words and actions
in person
you know when you see it's about time
and place it's so many different factors
it's nuanced I haven't said nuanced in a
long time y'all damn this is nuanced
this is nuance
like
if you're at a funeral
that is a factor that goes into how
you're going to talk to people around
you
you know if you're walking into a
funeral you ain't gonna walk into the
funeral like yeah
what up everybody who out here trying to
celebrate life there's just like you
there's an appropriate so you maybe you
wouldn't talk like that how would you
meet somebody at a funeral maybe you see
your girl at the funeral and you're like
oh uh Hey how do you know uh so-and-so
and they're like oh you know we worked
whatever and then all of a sudden you
have a sparked interest and you start
but you're not gonna do it like you're
not gonna have the same because of the
time and place you know what I'm saying
maybe you meet somebody at the library I
mean you don't even go to live say
bookstore Library I don't sound like an
old fogy you at the bookstore even a
bookstore it sounds like I'm an old
person but they still got Barnes and
Nobles you might be in the Barnes Noble
section you out in the uh psychology
section and you see a girl and she's in
the psychology section you might be like
hey how you doing what you know it's
like make a joke like you know what I
mean you know how many times I put
people at ease just by being like saying
something that like like I realize when
I'm out in public people are so not used
to just having conversations with people
it's so crazy I was at air one the other
day and there is this um this girl she's
standing there and I looked down and her
shoes are sneakers and slippers you know
and so I just was like wait are those
slipper sneakers and she was like looked
at me and she was like oh my God yeah
right isn't it crazy and then we just
had this conversation that was just like
oh this is how you spark conversations
with people people are ready to do it
people are ready to just talk about it
and it was all it was I was like uh well
those are cool I got to get some of
those she was like I know right oh my
God you know she walked away I walked
away and I was like oh I just had an
interaction with a human being and
everybody's ready to do it even when you
like have like you're buying something
and the person behind the counter and
you're like hey what's up and then you
have this like you feel like a
connection you know what I mean you you
it's it's okay to have a connection but
you young people you have lost the
ability or no no you're not even aware
of how strong physical
proximity Is to
communicating and connecting
you get lucky this is what you don't
realize when you swipe right are you
talking to somebody on Instagram are you
in the DMS for weeks and months and if
you meet them and it works you're lucky
you just got lucky
because
sometimes
that's not going to work and most of the
time it doesn't really work truly if you
really think about it
but there is something about
allowing a person into your Zone and
then let those vulnerabilities show also
it makes you like be on your p's and q's
your best behavior because think about
people just talking at home on the text
and they in their underwear
there's a certain Vibe you have at home
where you're so comfortable but you're
not really tough no I need to see
somebody get dressed up
you know who's had a bad day but they
trying to like be like hey how you doing
and they're trying to just still be
present be accountable for how I feel
you know regardless of how they feel
that's how it is to communicate and be
real with persons in real life you don't
need a damn social experiment to
physically talk to someone that's
ridiculous this generation is being
stunted your growth as human beings is
being stunted because you're so reliant
on this like physical superficial thing
look I I don't want to sit here and
sound like an old ass fogy man I'm not
trying to do that I'm just telling you I
appreciate the dating apps you know when
I was single I appreciate even just like
forget about just romance even just
interacting with your your fans and
people you don't know there's something
special about that like okay hey boom
boom boom boom and then you can move on
you know you know then you're like okay
that's a safe environment but if you're
trying to make friends you're trying to
get people with the same interest it's a
way to start but you have to get in
person experience body contact ex you
know a physical proximity experience
like pheromones do you guys even know
what that is look this [__] up man
pheromones you guys are missing out you
young men you missing out man you will
do so much better with women if you talk
to them in person even you guys you
think you ugly you think you're too fat
you think you don't have you know all
the things that like Society ID makes
you feel about yourself go get your game
right you can get your game by just
being you'll be surprised how first of
all women are as shallow as you think
they are you know what I mean they
really aren't they're not as shallow as
you think you are they are so much
smarter and more evolved emotionally as
creatures than we are as men women they
can feel that they they immediately be
like you know what they already
assessing you know you might you say you
too fat they're like but you know what I
like how sweet he is I like how whatever
he is I like how there's you can only do
that in person
uh
I'm moving on
I've talked about this too much
you hear me you don't need a social
experiment I thought that was like the
weirdest thing ever okay all right
moving on I was on one today about that
let's talk about some weird stories dude
I saw this this is so bizarre it's these
headphones it's these headphones that
clean your ears
like
shout out to this company Auto set ear
cleaning system right but it's like you
know you stick this thing in your ear
and you like water and then you can see
the the nastiness coming out of your
ears it's like 2 800 to have this like
who would pay that much money for this
right but it's supposed to help people
with hearing and all this kind of stuff
and somebody's trying to make a bunch of
money off this but this is the weirdest
[__] ever imagine you on a subway you on
the bus somebody come in they got
headphones like this and I'm just you
know I'm like yo I don't even know if
they really do music but I just when
they say headphones I think it's music
right so you just you know you boom and
then somebody you know and then like
somebody sit next to you and they see
like
you know wax and water building up
inside the thing right there and you are
like that yo what up what's up then you
like huh what's up
oh just that's my I'm cleaning my ears
you know but you know I'm also rocking
that Drake right now you know what I
mean so it's like oh dude yuck
yuck this would be like wearing this
would be like wearing clear pants that
they they all the pants also work as a
diaper and a toilet you know so you got
clear pants on you just walking around
and Boo-Boo is just sloshing around your
legs you know what I mean and you got
your cleaning headphones on and you're
like yo what up yeah I'm just what's up
yeah I just pooped that's what that is
had to take a big one right and that's
something yeah I'm cleaning my ears
right now too
like some that it just
uh
I just think that's nasty
foreign
[Music]
I don't know so crazy so how's the how's
the volume y'all I just didn't want to
ask the people listening live is my
volume okay right now I don't know I
gotta figure out what's going on I gotta
figure out what's going on with that if
the you know if the thing is coming out
too low I hope I hope it sounds good
anyways all right so that was that story
that wasn't one of the other crazy
stories of the week and if you got uh if
you got crazy stories that you want to
send me if you saw a really weird news
story that you're like yo I want to hear
what Griffin has to say about this send
it to me just email me at
ericgriffin.com or hit me in the
Instagram DMS you know just be like you
just started off with crazy story for
ripping with Griffin you know and then
you'd put a link and then I'll check it
out uh you know what I mean I'd love to
do that all right so all right so that
was a crazy one here's another weird
story that I saw just about some two
dumb inmates man the criminals are
stupid the fact that you know you even
in jail you know that's probably like a
sign that you just a dummy anyway
but this is just a weird ass story so
these two inmates were caught at IHOP
after allegedly using toothbrushes to
escape from a Virginia jail
so these two guys I
so you
so you Shawshank Redemption your way out
of prison okay
however long it took with these
toothbrushes that you dug a hole or
whatever you did to get out of the jail
and then you you you you escape from
jail and your plan is to go to a IHOP
nearby
what
did you do the fact that you're even in
jail like you already concocted this
great escape plan that actually worked
you used toothbrushes and now you you
get caught look at this there's the hole
right there so they they use
toothbrushes to dig this hole
they taught me took him a while you know
to get it right they did it they get out
and then they're playing they don't have
a plan they don't have like all right we
gonna do this get your girl to get my
passport the fake passport you know they
don't got an outside plan they just went
outside they they got outside of jail
like who
pancakes yeah man let's get some
pancakes then they went to IHOP like
this was some of the dumbest did you
as soon as they got outside the guy was
like yo man
Rudy Tutti fresh and fruity oh you
reading my mind homie
then they get they in IHOP
in their prison clothes by the way
right
they got their prison clothes on and
they went to freaking
[Laughter]
they got their orange jumpsuits on you
know and they like table for two you
know what I mean and you're just like uh
it's not Halloween but like what did
they even say were they just like yeah
costume party you know we going to this
work thing like we're like work is jail
you know like they didn't even I'm sure
they didn't even do nothing like that
there's just no thought process to it
they just sitting down just like yeah
let me get um
let me get to strawberry syrup please
which was the jam by the way at IHOP I
used to when I was when I used to go
when I was a kid you get the pancakes
you get regular syrup and strawberry
syrup and you mix them together so you
pour a little strawberry syrup on first
and then you put the maple syrup on oh
wait
I think I'm do I need to go to IHOP
y'all
oh man it's just it's so weird man and
thanks for being here Chad I see you
guys in the chat this is live I
appreciate you guys
uh everybody and thanks for all the
support you know super chats and all
that stuff and tips and you know being a
subscriber being a member all that kind
of stuff that you could do to help
support the show I appreciate it so
that's dumb stories of the week man
dumb weird stories of the week so I
appreciate it
um so I wanted to uh also talk about
let's let's talk about
um some reviews now so you know not
necessarily spoilers but I'm gonna try
not to spoil anything but I don't know
if you you know if you're watching but
it is what it is Mandalorian is back man
Mandalorian is back and to me
Mandalorian Mandalorian and Loki are
some of the best Disney Plus shows I
like Loki a lot and that's coming back
season two can't wait to see that but
Mandalorian is one of the best shows and
it really like opened up the Star Wars
Universe I love that I love that they're
doing that stuff I love all these shows
and actually between Mandalorian and or
two of the really great shows and or is
good too though you gotta watch that but
stick with Android stick with it it's
gonna get boring in the first like four
episodes there's gonna be moments where
you're gonna be like what is this but
trust me it picks up it's great so
Mandalorian is back you know Mando's
back uh played by you know Pedro Pascal
but here's one point I want to make okay
before I even get into this so you know
we talked about last of us last week
so we're looking at La I watched all of
Last of Us eight great episodes you know
there were some ups and downs but for
the overall it was a great overall Arc
like a great eight hour movie
and then I'm thinking about Mandalorian
and uh what where we've been through
Mandalorian to this point right now
played by the same character by the way
uh this is Pedro Pascal
and I realized
The Last of Us
and Mandalorian
they're the same show
you know what I mean
it's like it's the same like
concept it's like this guy who's you
know because Mandalorian has been you
know
he's not in the Society of mandalorians
anymore and you know he's I mean he goes
on his own path and he's
very Noble and but he's a killer you
know he's like you know he's probably
about killing people and then in Last of
Us he's the same kind of guy and he's
taken care of
this little girl you know he bonds with
this girl and he's the protector same
thing in Mandalorian this little Yoda
this little baby Yoda rogu whatever they
call him uh you know the Mandalorian is
doing the same thing so it's just Joel
in a Mandalorian suit you know taking
care of this little kid and then
you know Joel is taking care of you know
mandalorians taking care of the little
kid and then Joe's taking care of the
girl it's actually the same show and
they're all on an adventure they're on
this like Adventure to like achieve the
stuff together and I thought about it I
was like oh man we're watching the same
show it just shows you how like there's
not that many shows like no matter what
you surround the characters with you
surround them with zombies or you
surround them with space exploration
basically it's about how human beings
interact with each other and their
motivations on why they do things and
the Mandalorian and last of us they they
doing the same thing so I don't know
that's just my feeling tell me how you
feel about it in the comments uh give me
your thoughts you know there's there's
glaring obviously there's a lot of
differences but I'm just saying because
it's happening right now and it's the
same character same actor I'm saying so
you got you know Pedro Pascal this great
actor and he's like you know it's the
same energy you know it's like
mandalorians on the other show too but
anyways
first three episodes of Mandalorian you
know uh I don't know I'm kind of like
what's going on in this world now you
know it's like once they introduced who
the Mandalorian is like who is he like
like
what's his motivations and why he's
doing things now we're just kind of like
all right well what's next get to it I'm
getting the sip of my car I love coffee
I love coffee I got some great coffee
um
shout out to this Denver honey company
I'll tell you the name next week I think
it's called boers b b j o j i don't know
something something honey company
I bought it at the airport so good I got
this lavender honey it's delicious
anyways I digress honey commercial over
um so these first so now I'm kind of
like
I'm kind of like all right once you get
past the the fighting and the it's kind
of like mandalorians getting kind of
boring it's the same kind of thing it's
like here's this badass dude who like he
got this like Invincible armor on he's
got great skills he's rolling around
with this the little thing that like
really can take care of business if he
needs to little Yoda can be like you
know what I mean and then like you know
stuff starts floating around so they
actually a a a a pretty badass combo in
the same way and Last of Us how Ellie
could take care of herself too but
anyways I digress again
I hope that the show picks up you know
as of right now
in the show and I'm not revealing
anything
you know you know Mando remember in the
last season he took off his helmet and
this is the way you're not supposed to
do that which I fired by the way I
reject that premise of the mandalorians
in the first place covering their head
covering themselves for their whole life
it's like man you need some sun on your
face you know what I mean like I hope
they taking supplements or something
vitamin D or something like their faces
must be horrible right so
you know I I don't know so I sometimes
like I kind of can't get past that idea
but whatever I I actually you know I
suspend my disbelief so they got the
masks on right and you know so he took
it off because he needed to save himself
and whoever he was trying to save in the
last show in the last season right so
now he's been rejected from the
Mandalorian he's already I think I
believe in the show in the universe he
was already sort of kicked out of the
community and he's been trying to he's
been trying to uh get himself back and I
think when he like when he like went
against whoever with his job and he kept
the little Yoda Rogue when he kept you
know whatever the little thing's name is
when he kept that that's when he already
was like yo you're not supposed to do
that you're a bounty hunter and you know
whatever so like he's trying to he's
trying to get back into the community
because he's very Noble he's very
honorable and he's very like traditional
you know he's like this is the way and
so that's kind of what's happening right
now and I find it a little boring so far
but I know how these Star Wars shows go
so in the beginning when they're
establishing everything it's a little
bit boring and then they they really
have a great payoff so as of right now
I don't know if uh
grogu that's his name thank you chat
you know so we'll see we'll see you know
with this Disney you know with these
Star Wars shows
this is the way you know what I mean
this is the way
all right she spoiler alert coming right
now so if you want to watch this show on
Amazon Prime I want to talk about this
show it's called swarm
swarm y'all swarm it's on Amazon Prime
uh it's created by Donald Glover uh you
know from Atlanta the rapper like you
know very eccentric artist type guy man
and uh it stars Dominique flashback
is that her name Fishback flashback I
can't see Fishback Chloe Bailey but this
this girl
okay I don't even know where to begin
with swarm I don't even know where to
begin
last night so I started I told you like
I was saying earlier I've been seeing
some posts about the the the Culkin kid
one of the Culkin Brothers you know he
got this full frontal thing you know
anytime you see dick you're just like
Ugh okay too much dick in this it's kind
of you know what I mean but it's always
it's like a statement dick is always a
statement when you see it on in a show
or something they showing it for a
reason it's not like titties they're
just kind of like titties could just be
out you know what I mean and sometimes
you like why those titties out like it's
like okay titties are out but it's like
I don't know if it's necessary when you
see dick it's like okay we hey
dick you know what I mean they really
trying to like
show you stuff okay so
I was like let me check this show out I
didn't know what it was about until I
saw it I was watching Prime because I
just finished the consultant so I was
like let me see what else is on Prime
and I saw this and I saw this girl and
you know and so
when you see when you see this you just
go oh man what what is this about like
she has this sort of Dazed look on her
face and I'm like what is this about I'm
like oh [__] it's a black girl too I'm
like all right what's this about you
know and here's the thing too I'll say
about this you know when you start like
we live in this Society right now where
you know we're pushing for inclusion
we're pushing for diversity and it's
like so in that transition process it
could be weird for people you know like
I know a lot of white people listen to
podcasts and watch podcasts I know most
of you are white you know what I mean I
would probably say a majority of you are
white it's fine that's the podcast
Market you know and so you know you've
lived your life where like you know you
see people on TV that look like you and
you like you kind of connect with that
and you don't always connect with people
that don't look like you it's not racist
it's not whatever
and I don't like necessarily talking
about it but it's a podcast and I'm uh
you know I'm being introspective I'm I'm
I'm like analyzing the situation the
best of my ability and with my knowledge
of my 51 years and what I'm saying is
like a lot of times when you look at
when you're when you're not white when
I'm saying when you're white and you
look at a show like this you see this
there might be a something in you that's
like well what's this like you might be
like oh is this a black show you know
you might be like oh is this I don't
know as a person of color who grew up in
like a more
Prejudice society when I was younger you
know what I mean
when you're a person of color and the TV
comes on you don't even get to think
about that you know it's like one of my
favorite shows when I was a kid was
Dukes of Hazard I loved the Dukes of
Hazzard that was my it was my show I
never thought about like it was just it
never came to me like oh wow this is a
uh
a orange car with a Confederate flag on
the top with two country white boys
driving around a little big town you
know I never it's like having a you know
a a green Volkswagen with a swastika on
it
get on a mate I just I don't know I mean
maybe that's extreme but you know what I
mean so it's like you know when you know
you look you're coming up it's like I
watched Friends I watched uh Seinfeld I
watched Frasier I watched you know
Dynasty uh go back down I watched all
these like it's just like everything was
like all the actors were white you just
watch you just watch and you enjoy them
for the things that they are
like Dahmer like you watch Dahmer and
you see like the star of the show or
that other one mind mind uh mind
something whatever the one on uh Netflix
about the serial killers
um you guys will figure it out you'll
tell me in the chat you know it's like
that one it's like it's like you know uh
it goes way back to whenever and it's
like mostly mostly uh white people you
know what I mean so you just go okay so
anyway what am I talking about right now
what I'm saying is like when you watch
this you see this you're you know you
shouldn't judge a book by its cover but
you might be like you know what is this
I just I'm trying to tell you like push
past that if you do feel like that and
even if you're a person of color and you
see this we think the same thing I might
see this and be like what's this about
you know and that's a that's from like
years of non-diversity okay so all I'm
trying to say right now is like this
show deserves a watch for just the art
of it just the story like if you can get
past those societal feelings and things
that you might have your own like
prejudices that you don't even know you
have and how crazy our world is get past
it and watch this show
Donald Glover is a Madman he's a Madman
dude he's he's that kind of he's that
kind of artistic
Savant sort of like people throw the
word genius around a lot about people
and I that's the only word I can think
of without because I don't
it's just he's so authentically like the
things he comes up with this is the
weirdest damn show
I started watching this show last night
at whatever time I finished the whole
season last night
I was so enthralled by this show
um
I know you there's somebody in the chat
that I hate the person of color is
because it is what it is like I'm mixed
you know what I'm saying so that's the
closest thing I can say I don't want to
sit here and be like you know I'm black
I'm this I'm I'm half this I'm half that
I'm a person of color because there's
only two you know what I mean so that's
I I understand but I don't mean it that
way think of my intention not uh the
words you've heard from other people
other times just think of my intent
anyways this show
listen if you like did it's spoiler the
show is about this young girl okay she's
her she's she is obsessed with this
Beyonce type singer you know
there you know and here oh man I don't
even know how to even talk about this
correctly but there's this thing that
they do in the beginning in the
beginning of the show all right there's
a thing they do in the beginning of
every show where they say
um is this re is this real no this is
not a work of fiction they say you know
um
wait wait wait wait wait hold on I wanna
I wanna look this up for a second uh I
had it in my my web page my web page
closed okay so oh okay
this is how the show starts every
episode it goes this is not a work of
fiction
any similarity to actual persons living
or dead or actual events is intentional
it already blows your mind when you well
that's the one where you go huh you know
like this whole show is a mind [__] when
you're watching it man this show will
make you Google you will Google you're
gonna be like is this real what's going
on with this so you do that on your own
I'm not gonna tell you what I found okay
so the events of in the show even that's
a fiction it is a fictional story you
know but they used real murders so
anyway it's about this girl who's
obsessed with this singer in the show
her name's Naji but it represents and
and then they're called the Swarm which
is you know you know what you're saying
this is Beyonce fans
and how obsessed they are she's one of
these obsessed like super obsessed
troubled kids she was a troubled kid who
put her to who like used this fandom an
online world to like escape from her
troubles but she went too far she's too
deep in she has a tragic thing happen to
a family member and then she goes off
the deep end and then she turns into
Dahmer
that's I mean that's all I can say man
like she she is this is the illest show
I have seen in a long time man since the
the Dahmer one man
like this sucker is it's so bizarre what
she does the the series of events which
and how the story is told like kudos to
the writers and creators of this show
they tell the story in such a way that
you're just enthralled man
you really are enthralled you really
have to find ways to get into it and I'm
telling you at first I can see like At
first some people kind of being like
well I mean what is this is this like
Menace to Society or something you know
you know what I mean like it's like it
has a Vibe like that and I at first I
was like huh and then I started being
interested I was like oh wow there it's
very graphic it's very sexual it's very
like you know and the things that happen
you know you're just kind of like the
story isn't necessarily like telling a a
fluid Story from beginning to end it's
sort of like uh the stories are
connected and then they're not connected
the people are connected and they're not
connected they have this sort of like
documentary episode where you're you
really get mind blown because you're
like is this real is this is this like
is this what's going on here you know
the acting is superb like the dude won a
grant not a Grammy Emmy or a Golden
Globe for playing Dahmer okay
this girl right here Dominique Fishback
she acted her ass off in this show man
like
I they this show is gonna get something
it's gonna get something what is
happening in this show it just thinking
about society and the internet and how
people interact with each other and
Trauma and it deals with all of this in
such a way that I I don't know what to
say man
I'm not supposed I don't I don't want to
spoil it but I'm just telling you this
if you're into horror if you're into you
know like if you're into you know the
murderer stuff weird criminal stuff
this is the show man
I cannot recommend this show any higher
than I am doing right now I really can't
I I give that I get I would give it 20
woo-woos because I think it's that
fascinating of a show to watch I don't
know if the show is great I don't know
if the show is terrible but I'm telling
you this is a fascinating show
it's a fascinating show and I really I
want you to watch it and tell me about
it oh
[Music]
wow wow
all right John that was 20 woo-woos I
did it
um you know I mean
that just was the it just was such a
fascinating show to watch I mean I'm
telling you man I've been I binge
watched it y'all I just I couldn't stop
watching it last night I was up till
four o'clock in the morning that's why I
was late to do my podcast today because
I wanted to get up and do my podcast at
10 but I was so I was so tired
I was so tired that I couldn't even I
couldn't I couldn't even do it man all
right so that's just that's that you
know shout out to uh Donald Glover and
all the makers of the um that that show
man so make sure you guys check that
out well you know what time it is y'all
you know how we do every single week I
want to thank everybody uh for watching
riffing with Griffin every week you know
what I mean uh you know so it's like
make sure you uh check me out you know
I'm coming to your town I might be so
this in April in April I'm going to
Missouri uh at the um what is the name
of the club the blue room so I'm gonna
be in the blue room I'm coming to the
Louisville comedy club and I'm going to
the Mothership in Austin so check me out
my April is packed I'm gonna update my
website later so make sure you guys
check that out please subscribe and
share hit the notification so you know
when I'm going live I'm gonna attempt to
do this every Wednesday at 10 A.M so
look out for that pacific time so you
know we'll try to be more consistent
with that check me out on Twitch I'll be
on Twitch in like 20 minutes man 20
minutes I'll be on Twitch so come check
me out if you want to see me game my
game and I interact you know what I mean
it's always fun stuff patreon members
thanks for the support that's really
what it is it's support and I appreciate
it you could do be a YouTube number it
could be a page a subscriber on Twitch
be a subscriber on Twitch or you could
do do the patreon too however you want
to do that but you know you know how we
do it you know how we do it here on
River Griffin which the rap recap
that's how we do it
here on riffin Griffin
oh get out in public
[Music]
strive to stay alive
it's good
your word is born
show us Ill
give me a little chill
I have the thrill
like a three dollar bill
my rap style kills
because I'm the illest
thrillers
the chillest
[Music]
you don't need no stupid ass
social experiment yo young man get out
and meet those chicks
just don't lick your lips
foreign
[Music]
we here every week
and you can send me your own beat
[Music]
when I rap I know it's a treat
y
all right y'all
thanks for watching we're from with
Griffin we did it again
I hope the sound is good this week cause
everybody's complaining but listen I'll
see you next week y'all thanks for
watching
Griffin
[Music]